hi this is Peter Russell of university
of story
I am a story doctor in Hollywood I also
teach at UCLA and Pepperdine but in my
own school University of story you can
find what I'm talking about today what
I'm talking about today is television
because the television market is insane
right now I tell my students you are and
the luckiest people in the world to be
working in entertainment today because
there are so many hungry mouths in the
television world there is the network
there is the cable there is the internet
platform we've gone from 200 scripted
shows every year to over 400 in just
five years
so you're an insanely golden age of
television so we're gonna talk about TV
you know 80% of my business five years
ago was movies and I still do story
doctoring for movies but 80% of my
business now as a story doctor is for
television why is this well television
is different from movies but all the
patterns and secrets that I learned in
my career as a story doctor for movies
work in television and we're gonna see
that in a brilliant brilliant story
pilot of Breaking Bad tonight I want to
break down the pilot episode of Breaking
Bad probably in a way you've never seen
so you understand if you're writing an
hour drama just how its structured and
what the brilliance of this story is now
Breaking Bad is let's logline Breaking
Bad know a logline
in movies is a statement of how a hero
changes and heals but in a television
show a logline is different in the
television show a log on is simply the
heroes goals and the obstacles in his
way
what's the difference between these two
it's really critical in a movie you're
watching because you want to see the
hero change he can either get worse if
he can get better but he's changing he's
either healing a ripping open a core
wound in television a hero doesn't
change everything changes but the
characters in TV but what does change is
the character reveals new aspects of
himself and we're gonna see in Breaking
Bad today
that the hero in Breaking Bad's pilot
reveals new aspects of himself I also
want to tell you that in the television
pilot it's the only time in television
that you hero can change by the end of
this pilot Walter White has become what
he's gonna pretty much be for the next
seven years a drug-dealing murderer
he's gonna change marginally from
knowing out but his big change happens
in the pilot so what is that well I
always want to ask several questions
when we create a television show and
these are questions you should ask
yourself about your own show first of
all your logline is critical let me give
you the logline for Breaking Bad a high
school chemistry teacher dying of cancer
teams with a former student to
manufacture and sell crystal meth to
secure his family's future now that's
not a movie long line in a movie log
line you'd want to know what happened to
him right what happens does he do it
does he not does he heal does he stop
being a meth dealer no not in television
television is simply about goals and the
obstacles in the way because remember
we're telling a story that takes place
over a hundred to a hundred and fifty
episodes quite different from movies
although the same rules are used this is
a thriller and all my movie thriller
rules that I should give you in
university of stories thriller lecture
for movies also work in television I
have a television lecture at university
of story calm as well
what is this logline mean well when
you're recreating a television show
actually the creator of this television
show is brilliant Vince Gilligan was
actually he says sitting around
unemployed he's not at his idea he was
talking to his collaborator and he said
you know what we're broke we need money
maybe we should sell drugs and from that
kernel of an idea they started breaking
this log line now there's eight
questions I love to ask in television
one is what's the world of your show the
world of this show is Albuquerque New
Mexico now how the hell is that
interesting I'll tell you why because
it's literally
Albuquerque they shot it there and if
you know Hollywood you know that when
they make a middle class world they
usually put it up on a set in Riverside
and it's carpenter and it looks like
every other set you've ever seen but if
you actually shoot in the place you are
telling about you have a huge advantage
the French call it cinema verite we just
call it hey we got the budget to go on
location but it's the same thing because
it's real you really see the real
middle-class world of Albuquerque and
it's cool because it's so not cool
yes what's the premise here well what is
a premise in television it's a guy who's
gonna be selling drugs what's the
setting Albuquerque what's the theme
well I'll tell you a theme in television
is really important it's not like in
high school English where your teacher
asks you what's the theme of Julius
Caesar and you threw a spitball at her
the theme here is power corrupts and
absolute power crops and my father used
to say never corner a weak man you will
regret it Walter White is a weak guy
given power and we see what that does to
him it's a great theme the next thing we
ask in televisions what's the hook why
do we want to come back for 150 episodes
we don't need to do that in a movie but
we do in television what is the hook
here well what do you think the hook is
watching Walter White go from
mild-mannered geek to a drug-dealing
murderer
how far is Walter gonna go that's a
great question we're gonna I see it
every week the next thing is a genre
which is thriller we're gonna talk about
that as we go through this pilot episode
I'm gonna break it all down for you
you're gonna be using these hidden
patterns when you're writing your
television show matter what our John
root is there's 25 television John Rizzo
their own patterns if you don't know
them you're gonna get lost the next
thing is the character situation two
questions are going to keep us watching
for seven years what is the question
here well it's an unresolvable conflict
our dilemma now what do I mean by that
you don't need it in movies you have to
have it in TV what's an unresolvable
dilemma it is a question that will never
be satisfactorily answered okay
in Walters case it's this Walter wants
to save his family that's why he becomes
a drug dealer to make money but in doing
that he destroys his family
that's unresolvable it's called irony by
hipsters they must use it but
unresolvable dilemmas keep you coming
back to a television show you don't need
it in movies what's the unresolvable
conflict in say Mad Men Don Draper is a
traditionalist family man who was a big
great provider he's also a completely
amoral marriage wrecker unresolvable
dilemma will watch him for a hundred
episodes and he never resolves it yes
what's the unresolvable dilemma in Game
of Thrones
it's this how can good people prevail as
leaders when power corrupts absolutely
how come
good people never can become in charge
around the world you see crappy leaders
why what we're thirsting for is a good
leader but the very qualities that make
you a leader can preclude you from being
a good one so what's your story the next
thing we need are characters who
surprised us in television you must be
surprised
remember characters don't change they
just surprised when Janice shoots Richie
in that great episode of The Sopranos
and she kills him right there at the
dinner table with a pistol were shocked
were surprised were titillated do we
think Janice has changed no has Richie
changed well he's dead but no he's not
gonna change anymore he's dead but they
both surprised us Richie surprises by
hitting her for the first time she
surprises us by killing him with a
pistol big surprise this is how
television works finally what is a
character's superpower at the beginning
of a television pilot they are misusing
it Don Draper's misusing a seductive
abilities at the beginning of the first
episode of Mad Men tearing Lannister's
misusing his abilities at the first
episode of Game of Thrones
what is Walter White doing and breaking
he's misusing his genius for chemistry
he's misusing his genius for being
incredibly smart he's wasting his life
as a really bad high school teacher
doing nothing else he's going to be
using that in a really malevolent way
but boy is he using it the next thing
you need are structure and Dawg we're
gonna do talk about that as we go along
now
you